[Music]
the season one finale of 1883 the
paramount plus prequel series to
paramount's yellowstone might just be
the most heartbreaking episode in the
entire yellowstone franchise first and
foremost there are two major character
deaths in the finale both of whom
successfully reached the end of their
respective journeys before passing the
first is elsa dutton who after being
gravely wounded by an arrow makes her
father james promise that she can pick
the spot where she will die she ends up
choosing a small tree in the gorgeous
paradise valley and dies peacefully in
her father's arms the scene is
gut-wrenching and tragic though the
episode's second major death is by far
the more brutal of the two in a time
skip forward we watch as shae brennan
finally completes his journey to the
west coast and sits on a beach in oregon
to watch the waves crash against the
shore it was revealed earlier in the
series that shea's only reason for
making the journey west was because of a
promise he made to his wife helen who
desperately wanted to see the ocean just
look at that helen
beautiful
helen died prior to the series start so
shea took it upon himself to let her see
the ocean through his eyes shea's
promise is finally fulfilled and after
staring at the waves for a while he
kills himself so that he can finally be
with his wife once more
given how well audiences had gotten to
know shay throughout 1883 season 1 his
death is undeniably sad although there
is a silver lining that makes the scene
a bit less heartbreaking the unexpected
appearance of a hummingbird on the beach
which flits around for a moment looking
right at him as if it's trying to get
his attention it doesn't stay long
though and when it leaves a smile widens
across jay's face who has finally found
peace in his final moments the 1883
reddit community naturally began
speculating on what this scene and the
bird itself means a prevalent theory is
that the hummingbird symbolizes someone
visiting shae from beyond the grave
specifically his late wife helen it
could be that the hummingbird is indeed
shay's wife who comes to see him at the
end of their long journey to oregon
after all seeing what was supposed to be
their adventure through to the end was
shay's driving purpose all along so it
makes thematic sense still other fans
seem to believe that it's actually an
entirely different deceased character
one reddit user wrote it was elsa the
symbolism of the hummingbird is the
epitome of her remember her talking
about birds in her final moment other
users referenced elsa's conversation
with shea earlier in the episode which
seems to foreshadow his meeting with the
bird as one poster wrote elsa did tell
him to save a spot for her at the beach
if she didn't survive it seems entirely
possible that the hummingbird is meant
to symbolize elsa coming back to visit
shea just like she said she would come
at you on the beach
i'll save your spot then there's the
third camp which includes people who
just found the whole scene absolutely
tear-jerking and didn't dwell much on
the symbolism at all calling the scene
sad but also beautiful one person posted
shea on the beach with the hummingbird
really got me i know his body and soul
were tired and he was ready to be with
his wife and daughter other users wrote
that they loved shay and elsa's
connection throughout the first season
of the series all the way up to the
bittersweet end regardless of who the
hummingbird really is its appearance is
undeniably heartwarming and makes an
incredibly emotional scene even more
powerful shea brennan's life was
dominated by war loss and sadness which
compounded to create the gruff
no-nonsense attitude that became his
trademark at least when he sat on that
beach looked on at the vastness of the
ocean and had the chance to breathe just
a little easier he didn't have to do so
alone check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies and tv shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]